welcome
thanks for having me welcome my man
appreciate it good to see you you've
been making some [ __ ] noise
congratulations on the new situation
with my man boozy yeah my dog big dog I
always tell people that uh you know when
you meet certain celebrities usually
they disappoint you except for if you
meet boozy you ain't gonna disappoint
you he's exactly who you [ __ ] see
online that's exactly what you said yeah
for sure don't play with them so
originally you bought a feature from him
right right and so he just [ __ ] with
it so much and [ __ ] with y'all like
was it like did you buy the feature in
the video or like how did it about the
feature and the video but
it that was four years ago it was a long
time ago it was a long time ago like so
he he's he must have was thinking just
waiting watching me work let me see what
he gonna do paying attention paid
attention and came and got me like wow
what the hood yeah that's crazy what if
you don't mind me asking what was the
what was the bag for the feature and the
video four years ago
this 15. that's not bad no I ain't bad
that's not bad at all it was good it was
a good investment for me of course four
years later I'm [ __ ] with the biggest
yeah I'm cool with that and like I think
too like Boosie's got like a very like a
underrated track record when it comes to
like signing artists because a lot of
people like young blue you know what I'm
saying that's he's the guy who believed
in blue first exactly 100 man what part
of me